ayer viernes cuando el gobierno había
organizado decenas de movilizaciones en
el país para recordar esa toma de la
embajada estadounidense en 1979 por un
grupo de estudiantes revolucionarios
unas movilizaciones que se convirtieron
en jornadas de apoyo al gobierno había
una provincia en especial en Irán donde
se estaban llevando a cabo fuertes
protestas es la región del sistema
luchistán en el sur del país una de las
más aisladas y las más pobres de la
región donde decenas de personas o miles
de personas salieron a protestar y
fueron fuertemente reprimidas por las
autoridades especialmente en la ciudad
de una ciudad de al menos 60.000
habitantes donde al menos 16 personas
habrían muerto y decenas habrían quedado
heridas en escenas que se han sido
registradas en videos que se han ido
subiendo a la web dicen que los
hospitales estaban colapsados pero esta
no es la primera vez en que la región
del sistema se ha vuelto un escenario de
estas protestas ya el 30 de diciembre
miles de personas en la capital sagedán
habían salido a protestar porque una
joven que había sido detenida por la
policía se había conocido que había sido
abusada sexualmente esta masa fue
reprimida fue recibida con disparos por
las autoridades y según organizaciones
de Derechos Humanos al menos 90 personas
murieron en aquella ocasión todos estos
actos han llevado a que el líder sunita
de esta región una región que si bien es
sunita de mayoría está en un país de
mayoría Chita se convierta en uno de los
líderes más críticos con el gobierno de
Teherán ha criticado la manera como ha
reprimido estas protestas pero también
les decía que la población no está
contenta con ellos que es hora de hacer
un referéndum con intermediación y
vigilancia internacional y que si la
población dice que no los quiere pues
que acepten el resultado